nous retrouvons dr karl weiss président
de l'association des médecins
microbiologiste-infectiologue du québec
bonsoir dr weiss je vous montre un petit
tableau tout simple le nombre de gens
encore infectés dans les résidences pour
personnes âgées 2725 dans 340
établissements touchés en a 42 qui
inquiète particulièrement des sièges
celle des sur les on va voir la carte du
québec sur les 74 dessin depuis hier dr
weill il y en a 70 on voit une
augmentation de 74 décès il y en a
soixante dix qui sont survenus dans les
résidences pour personnes âgées
alors ma question comme s'est vraiment
concentré
j'allais dire de plus en plus dans les
résidences personnes âgées
beaucoup de gens me pose la question
pourquoi on a si peur de descons filet à
ce moment là la société qui ailleurs par
ailleurs je vais vous donner deux
exemples précis il ya de dison jeu en
exemple de deux pays dans le monde qui
ont très bien réussi au niveau de la
première vague qui sont la corée du sud
et israël qui ont des confiné beaucoup
ces derniers temps puisque justement ils
ont très bien réussi
et ces deux pays là commence à avoir un
petit peu plus de cas aujourd'hui et
hier les deux donc ça vous montre et il
s'attendait d'ailleurs à ça donc ça vous
montre que des vous commencez à des
confiné fonctions il est prêt à payer un
certain prix
alors oui c'est vrai que en veillant au
des configs il faut pas se leurrer au
québec à l'activité vous avez juste à
regarder des rues le trafic la
circulation et on voit qu'une
augmentation est présent alors ce qui
arrive c'est que si on les confine un
peu n'importe comment
ben on va avoir beaucoup plus de cas sur
une courte période de temps et on va
revenir à une période et une étape là on
va avoir pas des gens dans les chsct
mais on va voir des gens relativement
plus jeunes et relativement plus en
bonne santé qui vont être malade comme
on a eu au tout début de la pandémie au
tout début de la pandémie ce n'était pas
les chs ldc des gens qui revenait de
voyage était relativement en bonne santé
beaucoup étaient bons en relativement
tiré de groupes d'âge on va dire d'âge
moyen et on se retrouvait avec ces gens
là dans les hôpitaux dans les soins
intensifs
donc faut faire attention à avoir un
déconfinement qui seraient trop rapide
et n'importe comment
d'autant plus qu'on n'a pas de
médicaments et on a pas de vaccin mais
même s'ils ont même oublié le vaccin si
on avait juste un médicament on pouvait
donner la prophylaxie ou en traitement
se serait déjà quelque chose et on n'est
même pas rendus là donc donc vous
comprenez tout à fait les
recommandations et la répétition que
fait 116 le docteur arruda qu'un il dit
c'est fragile encore à montréal il faut
être prudent parce qu'on voudrait pas
être obligé de reconfirmer vous dites
c'est possible je ne faut pas faut pas
croire que ce sont que des une marotte
qu'on répète là ça peut couver comme un
incendie de forêt il sa peur pour
revenir en réalité et les braises sont
très loin d'être éteinte et je vous
dirais qu'il ya même des petits foyers
ici et là qui sont encore allumée donc
l'idée c'est qu'on vous autorise un
marché un petit peu dans la forêt en
sachant très bien que on pourrait à un
moment donné vous faire sortir de la
forêt très rapidement si on reprenait
l'image de l' incendie dans la situation
est très loin d'être contrôlé vous
rappelez on parlait un moment donné
d'une diminution du nombre de décès au
québec
puis il ya eu quelques journées où
c'était peut-être un peu moins mais on
vous voyait encore une fois que le
nombre de décès à avoisine encore les
70-75 par jour oui mais alors on diminue
les jours sans solde et mai mais ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'il ya encore de
l'activité du virus
si ces gens l'un des sels pour certains
d'entre eux c'est parce qu'ils ont été
malades
ils ont attrapé le virus il ya quelqu'un
qui leur a donné des gens qui s'occupent
de ces gens-là et des gens qui vont
parfois visiter ces gens là donc le
risque d'avoir encore du virus qui se
propage existe tout à fait prenons le
reste du québec
ça fait quoi trois semaines là que les
écoles ont repris que on a des confiner
les commerces etc et on n'a pas vu quand
même de résurgence importante de cale
dans la population générale je parle
parle pas dans l'hérésie
personnes âgées oui ça c'est parce que
comme on en avait expliqué il ya trois
épidémies au québec
morial l'île de montréal et 10 en aval
il ya la ceinture de montréal de 4 5 0
la rive nan lari dessus et il reste du
québec
le reste du québec à une relative petite
pandémie à hadath donc finalement n'ont
pas eu beaucoup de cas il ya des régions
qui ont été très épargné n'oubliez pas
que dans ces régions là même s'ils ont
des consignes on dit aux gens de porter
des masques on regarde des aspects de
distanciation physique on encourage
toutes les mesures de prévention des
infections
on n'est pas complètement retournée à
l'école comme on est retournés avant on
n'est pas complètement retourné au
travail les restaurants sont encore
fermés bon on n'est pas vendu dans notre
vie normale
donc on a encore des mesures que
j'appellerais de mitigation pour aplanir
le plus possible l'impact de lakovic 19
même dans ces régions qui ont été peu
affectés alors le risque à montréal
c'est qu'à un moment donné les choses
s'enflamme pour mais une augmentation
rapide du nombre de cas et comme on
avait déjà dit même si vous avez
seulement 5 % des gens qui vont devenir
très madame 5% de sangin et 5% en 2000
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose à 5%
mais en nombre absolu
ça fait beaucoup de monde a traités dans
les hôpitaux donc les consignes de
prudence pour montréal
vous les encourager vous les comprenez
totalement totalement pour le québec au
complet parce que là c'est même si
ailleurs ça va mieux on n'a pas le choix
que d'être non mais d'un autre côté on
n'a pas le choix de des confiné non plus
pour plein de raisons des raisons
sociales des raisons économiques des
raisons de santé
surtout vous savez il ya beaucoup de
choses qui va falloir reprendre comme
activité on ya plein de choses qu'on
fait pas en médecine actuellement on
devrait recommencer à faire de façon
assez rapide
alors on ne peut pas rester dans une
situation où tout le monde était confiné
advitam eternam
en attendant l'arrivée possible d'un
vaccin donc je dis possible parce qu'on
parle de vaccins mais vous savez que
c'est pas une garantie absolue qu'on
finit par avoir un vaccin non plus on
atteint une phrase que les gens répètent
comme sten une
une chose évidente qui allait avoir une
deuxième vague une deuxième vague des
gens dit c'est pas si c'est quand vous
êtes d'accord avec ça que vous quand à
l'automne c'est sûr qu'il y aura plus de
cas à moi ce que je vous dirais c'est la
première chose c'est qu'il y en aura
d'autres vagues
on aura peut-être une 2e 3e 4e en aura
des vaguelettes où on aura une grosse
vague des petites vannes on aura des
petites vagues d'une grosse fan
l'automne bas est une série une
situation propice à avoir une vague avec
une grosse importance parce que là on
pense le retour à l'école qui sera
beaucoup plus intense on pense au retour
au travail
on pense aussi un ensemble de facteurs
un peu comme les virus de la grippe et
cetera où c'est à ce moment là de la
saison respiratoires débute donc tout ça
mis ensemble et là on n'aura toujours
pas de vaccin pour être réelle va se
reparaître l'a29 malheureusement vous
vous arrêtez pas c'est tout le temps que
j'ai ça va être la publicité qui va nous
couper docteur vin est très gentil
d'être là on se reparle merci au revoir